>> BOYD: Hello, everyone. My name is Ryan
Boyd and this is Steve Bazyl...
>> BAZYL: Hi.
>> BOYD: ...and we're here today to talk about
"Integrating your app with the Google Apps
Marketplace." Before we get started, I do
want to give you this URL: http://bit.ly/appswave,
where you can view live notes and ask questions
you have about this session in Google Wave.
We'd probably be going through that a bit
at the end, I'm sure you're used to this already,
so. The other thing before we start is I want
to introduce two things to you here. I want
to talk first about the company called Smart
Lawfirm. It's a lawfirm that uses Google Apps
for their business to do email encounter in
docs and that sort of thing. And they use
this application called SaaSy Voice which
is a sample application we wrote for small
and medium size businesses to do voicemail.
It uses the toolio APIs which are awesome,
give a call to those folks. All right. The
agenda; first of all, we want to give an overview
of the Google Apps Marketplace. How many of
you already went to a kind of the business
session on the Google Apps Marketplace earlier
today? Okay, there are some hands, but not
all of you. So, try not to fall asleep during
that section, but there's going to be a little
bit of repeat material there for a couple
of minutes. But then, we're going to get in
to actually launching the SaaSy Voice application
on the marketplace, and go through each of
the steps that you need to do to launch the
application on the marketplace, then talk
a little bit about the road map, and then
go into the Q&A period that we talked about.
Okay. So, the marketplace; well, Google Apps
were focused on messaging and collaboration.
We have apps like the Gmail, the Calendar,
the Docs, all sorts of different types of
apps that are really meant to provide businesses
all of their messaging and collaboration tools
they need without the usual hassle of IT administration.
But our customers want more great cloud applications.
They want applications which do things like
CRM, or project management, types of applications
that we don't offer in the native Google Apps
but we can work together with you as developers
to build those applications and offer them
jointly to our customers. So here's the basic
steps for selling your application on the
Google Apps Marketplace, and really, you know,
fulfilling the need for all those different
types of applications. First of all, you build
your app. How many of actually already have
a SAS application which you, you know, have
out there for sale already? Okay. How many
of you are actually trying to launch a SAS
application that you're trying to sell? All
right. So, it gives a little idea to breakdown
here. You can build your app using any tools
and any hosting provider you want. I mean
you're at Google I/O, you're well aware of
all the great tools that we provide for development
such as the Google Web Toolkit or the hosting
of App Engine, but these aren't required.
I want to make sure that's clear, these aren't
required to launch your application on the
Google Apps Marketplace, you can use whatever
tools or hosting provider you want. The next
step is integrate your application with Google
Apps. With the minimum point of integration
here is the single sign on by OpenID. We want
to make sure that our, you know, customers
have a real seamless flow to get into your
application and get using it without having
to create another username and password. But
there all sorts of other different integration
points that are available for you as developers
to offer greater value to your customers.
You can integrate with Docs, you can integrate
Calendar, Contacts, all sorts of things and
we will be talking about some of those in
the remaining part of this presentation. Of
course the next step is probably the most
important step for most of you and that's
selling your application in the marketplace.
There are over two million businesses which
use Google Apps, with over 25 million users
in those businesses. And we're adding like
3,000 new businesses a day, so there's a huge
audience to sell these applications to. You
can also work with our reseller channels,
there's about thousand resellers on the ground
selling Google Apps and they would be happy
to talk with you, I'm sure, if their--if your
solution offers value for their customers.
And then, you basically get to go wherever
Google Apps goes. And for all of that, there's
a one time listing fee of $100 and then a
20% rev share which is going to start in the
second half of this year after we release
our billing APIs and we're going to be talking
about those too. So now that you've built
and launched your application on the marketplace,
our customers have everything that they need
in the cloud and your joint customers as well.
So they have the project management app, they
have the sales and marketing apps, all of
these in addition to the, you know, the native
messaging and communication apps that Google
Apps provides. So now, we really want to dive
in to building the SaaSy Voice application.
We're going to first start here talking about
the SaaSy Voice application as it existed
prior to being listed on the marketplace.
We're going to show you the features of that
application and then Steve is going to show
you diving into the integrations with Google
Apps. So there are basic features; first of
all, you can create a new account as a business,
you can provision phone numbers for the employees
of your business, and create and assign extensions,
and then you can show the voicemails; every
employee can see their voicemails that came
into the system. And hop over here to that
actual Web browser. So this looks like, you
know, many applications you're already probably
familiar with; the login page, and then an
option to create accounts. So if you're going
to create account or asked to type in some
information here--I'm going to pretend I'm
a partner at the Smart Lawfirm--switching
careers here a little bit but, type in passwords
here. My domain is Smart Lawfirm. The company
name is Smart Lawfirm, the name of the card.
I'm going to actually steal Steve's credit
card here and use that. Steve, what's your
credit card number? All right. I'll skip that
part here. Head purchase. So now, I signed
out as a customer to--for the SaaSy Voice
application, for my business, Smart Lawfirm.
And I can go through here and enter in all
the different, you know, people in my company.
So, I can fill in Mary, John, Jane, Steve;
I mean I can fill all these people and there's
like 20 people that work for my company. I'd
actually have to remember all the first names
and last names and for those of you who know
me, I'm a little bit bad with names so, this
will be very difficult for me to do. But we're
going to show how that gets a lot easier when
this application is listed on the Google Apps
Marketplace. So, after I fill out the list
of, you know, each of the employees at the
Smart Lawfirm, then they'll probably each
receive an email that looks something like
this. They're asked to click on that link
and create a password. So they clicked on
that link, they enter their email address,
they enter a new password, and then, finally,
after they do that, they're in to see their
voicemail. All of these can be, you know,
drastically improved. We can really improve
the user experience here based off the information
that we have with Google Apps. So now, Steve
is going to come up here and talk about integrating
SaaSy Voice with Google Apps and go through
many of the APIs.
>> BAZYL: Thanks, Ryan. I'd like to share
you the integrated version and we'll take
a look at a demo of that application, followed
up by dive into the code itself for how we
did various integrations. Before we do that,
I want to talk a little bit about the process
of integrating. The first thing you need is
an application. Today, we're talking about
SaaSy Voice but a few of you, you know, raised
your hand that you have an application that
you think would be a good integration with
Google Apps. Once you have your application,
Google Apps has a set of APIs that allow you
to access customer data. This includes things
like Contacts, Calendars, your Documents,
even their email, and you can also things
like single sign on with OpenID. Here you
have to write code, right. This is the developer
conference where developers, you know, this
is what we get paid to do. You have to write
a code to get and set data. You have to write
code to do something interesting with that
data in your application. Once you have your
application integrated with Google Apps, you
need to describe that integration in a simple
XML document that we call a manifest. Here,
you would list the URLs for your application,
various entry points. You would also describe
the APIs that you use. You upload this into
the marketplace and it allows Google to make
sure all the write bits are set and the write
permissions are granted when an administrator
installs your application. So we can actually
see this with the new version of Saasy Voice.
I switched over here, and here we're actually
logged in into the marketplace as a vendor.
We haven't published our application yet,
but we can still preview it and install it
using the same process that any customer would
go through. So, we're going to click "add
it now" button, and install it onto the same
domain that Ryan did before here. I need to
be an administrator to install an app on my
domain, so I'm going to login. Fortunately,
I do have administrator permissions, and we're
going to see step one of the installation.
And here, which is asking us to agree to the
apps terms of service. It doesn't look too
complicated. Don't need a lawyer to review
this for me, so I'm going to agree and continue
with the installation. The second step is
probably the most important step of the installation
process. And you have to make a critical decision
here about two things. One is do you trust
the application developer? And two, is the
API usage that is asking for appropriate for
the application? For the first question, do
I trust the developer? Yeah, Ryan looks pretty
innocent. You know, I'm happy with him. I'm
not going to worry that he's going to steal
any of my data. So let me just take a look
at, you know, the APIs that we're using. It's
asking for the user provisioning API to help
us set up our accounts. It's seems reasonable.
It wants to export information into our doc
list and it wants to use the context to display
information about people who leave voicemail
messages. It seems like a reasonable set of
APIs for the application. I trust Ryan. I'm
going to agree and grant him access. This
next step is an optional step that not every
application in the marketplace offers. Because
SaaSy Voice is, you know, we have to allocate
a new phone number for customers, we have
to set up voicemail extensions and we want
to collect payment information, we want to
do all those before we enable the application
for all the users on the domain. So, I'm going
to click through here, and you're also going
see the first integration point which is a
single sign on. So even though I don't have
an account with SaaSy Voice yet, as soon as
I click that link, the application was able
to authenticate me and create a new account.
So they can pair those to the first version
of the application that you saw, the installation
process is already a lot easier. I don't have
to enter in my email address, I don't have
to create a new password, I only need to supply
a little bit of information about our company,
and then I can continue. And one thing I want
to know is, you know, while you're seeing
this in the context of the administrator,
the real power is, this feature is available
to every user for every application that they
purchase. Just like a user can switch seamlessly
between Gmail, Calendar, Contacts, Docs; we
expect that they can switch between Gmail
and a third party application just as easily.
So I'm going to continue here. And you'll
see the second integration point which is
using the user provisioning API to get information
about all the users in the domain. When Ryan
went through this earlier, he was presented
with a big empty form, and it would have taken
him a lot of time to go and collect the information
about all of his employees. Here, the application
has spurred enough to recognize I'm a Google
Apps customer, let me go get that data for
you. So that was administrator, all I need
to do is review the information, make sure
it looks okay and approve it. So, I'm really
happy I got 10 minutes back. I'm going to
approve it and we're actually done with the
setup and I can enable it for all the users
in my domain, really simple. So let's actually
take a look at how this is done. So a single
sign on as I mentioned before is done with
OpenID. OpenID is an open protocol for authentication
on the Web and it allows the user to authenticate
with multiple websites but without sharing
sensitive information like their credentials.
Unfortunately, we don't have a lot of time
to go very deep into OpenID, so you may hear
or see things in the code that maybe a little
bit confusing. Don't worry about these. You
don't need to understand all of the details
right now, and the reason is it's actually
quite easy to implement OpenID, thanks to
a lot of good libraries. Most of these are
open source. The code that we're going to
look at is from the PHP OpenID library, SaaSy
Voice is a PHP app. And that library, it's
an open source library, developed by John
Reign. And we're also using a small add-on
library that's available on code.google.com,
that just makes it easier to work with Google
Apps. So let's look at the code and just broke
this down into three simple steps, one is
you just to initialize the library; the second,
to make the authentication request; and the
third, to hand all the request to response
back and log the user in. So our first step
here is we need to, you know, get, build-up
the library. So we're holding a consumer which
is our entry point into the library. And to
do that, we need some storage. This is just
the storage information about the identity
providers that we're talking to. We're using
memcache which is perfectly fine in this case.
We create our consumer and then we have to
call one helper method. And what this does
is it allows us to authenticate users for
Google Apps knowing just their domain. In
this case from coming from smartlawfirm.com
it will know how to authenticate me based
on that information. We return our consumer
and we're good to go. So now, we have a library
and we could use that to authenticate a user
when we have our application. So first thing
we need to do is actually, you know, make
an authentication request for that user's
domain. There are a lot of OpenID providers
out there that you can authenticate to, so
in order to do that, you need to say, "Who
am I going to authenticate it with?" For Google
Apps, we use the domain name and there's two
ways I can get those information. In the demo,
what you saw was that domain name being supplied
automatically in the URL. That is done with
a very simple template mechanism that is available
to [INDISTINCT]. If somebody was coming straight
to my website, I might want to display a form
that says, "Please entry your email address"
or "Enter your Google Apps domain in order
to log in." So once we have their information,
we can create a request but before we send
the user off to authenticate, we want to get
a little bit more detail about them. We want
to get their email address and their names
so we can get a little bit more personalization
in our app. OpenID has an extension called
attribute exchange which allows for this.
So we're going to create that extension and
we're going to add a couple lines to request
email, first name and last name. And then,
we're going to add that extension entry request
and then we're good to go. We, but we still
need to get the user over to the identity
provider and so we'll do that by rendering
a form which in JavaScript so that it will
post the request over to Google. And the only
reason we're doing the post here instead of
a redirect is simply because this request
can get very large depending on how much data
you're asking for the length to the domain
name. And this is just the safest way to deal
with some of the limitations that you might
encounter with very long URLs. So, you know,
so far what we've done is, you know, we have
our library, we sent it, you know, done a
request from the user, send a request, they're
now over at their identity provider, in this
case, Google Apps, and they're being authenticated.
Once that's done, they're going to come back
and we're going to get a post back from Google
that has the details and the result of the
authentication so it handle the response.
Very similar as before, we basically just
call a simple method to partial all the response
data and the libraries make this really easy
and we just want to make sure everything was
successful. In this case, this is our happy
path and where a user was authenticated and
we'll pull out some information. The most
important piece of information we get here
is their identifier. This is a stable unique
identifier that we can use to correlate, you
know, all log-ons for that user. But it's
anonymous, it's doesn't really tell us who
that person is. That's why we ask for things
like their email address or first name and
their last name. So we'll pull this out from
the response, and now that we have all this
information, we can map that user to somebody
on our database or create a new account if
that's what we need to do. And once we have
that, we can add them to the session, let
them log-in to the app and they're logged
in, they never enter their username or a password,
it all just happens the OpenID. One last bit
of information that we need to provide is
information in the manifest that describes
how people access our application and there
are three things I want to point out in this
part of the manifest. The first is the URL
that we saw during the setup process. And
here we can also see the template mechanism
that I've mentioned earlier that allows you
to get the domain name that the users are
coming from after they've installed. The two
extensions; one is actually for the place
in navigation element in Google Apps. Installed
applications can get a menu link alongside
all the links that you have in Google Apps
for Gmail, Calendar, Docs, and the other Google
services. Third party applications are first-class
citizens, they get placed up there. The last
of bit is the OpenID realm and this is actually
a very important thing. By declaring your
OpenID realm, it allows Google Apps to recognize
authentication request from an installed application.
This allows us to make the user experience
a little bit better because since the administrator
installed the application and explicitly trusted
it, we don't need to ask each individual user
to approve the OpenID request and, you know,
to approve the sharing of their personal information.
Saasy manifest, we have this uploaded and
now app, we can do single sign on. The user
experience as you saw earlier is very smooth.
Before we get into the data access, I just
want to do a quick recap on single sign on.
You see, what you saw with this is with, you
know, a little bit of code in PHP, you know,
not much more than, apparent less than a 100
lines.
We were able to get, you know, authenticate
the user. We were able to get their, you know,
their unique identity along with some personal
information about them. One quick note is
on things like email--you still want to do
things like, you know, send a confirmation
message to make sure that, you know, they
really own that email address or you want
to do something like a white list trusted
providers. Since Google Apps is managed, you
can actually trust the email addresses and
it's very simple to add a line or code to
say if this, you know, if this response is
from google.com, we don't need to actually
validate the message, we know it's good. So
I'll switch gears a little bit to Data Access.
Data Access is done with the Google Data APIs.
These are restful APIs built on the Atom Publishing
Protocol. And, you know, they're pretty easy
to use basically because there's a lot of
great libraries out there. Libraries in most
languages--today, we're looking at code with
this and, you know, GData library. First thing
we have to worry about though is how do we
actually get access to the user's data? All
right, we need to be authorized to do that.
And the way you do that with GData is with
OAuth. And OAuth is simply it's an open standard
protocol for allowing a third, for basically
delegating access to a third party in a secure
way. For marketplace, we use a variation called
2-legged OAuth. In traditional OAuth that
approval in that delegation step is done on
an individual user basis. So the first time
a user wants to grant your application access
to context, you have to request that access,
the user will see a pop-up asking for authorization
in which in that data establishes, you know
that everything is good to go. In 2-legged
OAuth, we actually do that at the, at install
time and it's done by the administrator on
behalf of all the users in the domain. The
way we do this is by listing the APIs or in
this case the scopes that we want in the manifest.
And as you saw earlier during the install
process, the administrator is then asked to
approve that. Once that approval is given,
the application then come in to access the
APIs on behalf of all the users in that particular
domain. They don't have to ask, you know,
each individual user to approve a request
to open for them. So on the Data Access side,
we're actually, just going to break this down
into two pretty simple steps. One, you know,
as we did an OpenID, let's just, you know,
initialize the library. In this case, we're
just doing this just to establish our credentials
for application. We need tidbits of information
here. We need to know our consumer key and
our secret. These are the equivalents of our
applications, username and password. The rest
here is just, you know, mostly boilerplate
codes and we're going to use, you know, a
signature here to sign the request with our
key and secret. We're going to, you know,
pass this as a request header and against
some more boilerplate codes to initialize
the library. What this gives us now is we
now have an HttpClient that is initialized
with our application credentials and we can
use that to access the data on behalf of the
user that installed our application. So let's
take a look at how we did that with the Provisioning
API. We start with our client that we just
created and, you know, create a service object
around it. This is simply a helper object
that makes working with the Google APIs a
little bit easier, and we make a query. So
for the Provisioning API, the query that we're
making is get me the users for a particular
domain and that we're using the currently
logged on users domain and this we can actually
get from the, you know, the URL, we can get
it from their email address or from their
OpenID. We make that query and what we get
back is a list of users and we can simply
iterate through these, extract out the key
bits of information that we want, in this
case, we want username, their first last names
whether or not they're administrator. And
now we can take this data and use it on our
application in a meaningful way. In this case,
what you saw earlier was using it to pre-populate
the database and pre-populate that form to
make the setup a lot easier for the administrator.
So I'm going to switch over to the demo again
and show this from the user's perspective.
So switch over to Gmail and here you can actually
see this navigation menu that I mentioned
earlier where along with Mail, Calendar, Documents
and sites, we have a list of additional application
that we installed, and these were actually
applications from the marketplace. Some of
these are new, some of these are, were around
at launch but I care about SaaSy Voice. So
got to click over and just like we were signed
in seamlessly before, as the administrator,
I get the same experience as a user. Although,
right now, it seems to be acting a little
bit slow--that's okay we can wait just a sec
for the demo. All right, there we go. So I
didn't have to enter a username or password,
I just clicked the link, I'm signed in and
I'm not seeing any data. There we go. So here
we actually have our voicemails for this user
and already somebody left me a voicemail,
this is one from one of our favorite customers
Litigious Larry. He's really, really good
business for the Lawfirm. See if I can actually
play his message.
>> LARRY: Hey, Steve this is Larry, just want
to follow-up about my most recent case in
[INDISTINCT] Hospital. Let me know how it's
going. Thanks.
>> BAZYL: So there's Larry, getting, a really
great customer for us. But one thing you'll
notice here is another integration point.
Instead of just showing a caller ID information,
his phone number or just, you know, a simple
name. What we're seeing here is information
from our contacts and so, you know, basically
by joining that phone number against our contacts'
database from Google Apps, we can show more
contacts in our voicemail. So if I want to
call Larry back on his cell phone, I see those
here. If instead of calling him back, I just
want to send him a quick email. I can click
that link and I get my Gmail compose window
and I can just send him a quick note, except,
have a little bug in there that I hope that
you noticed. The other integration I want
to show is on the call log. So as an administrator
I can see all the voicemails and all the calls
that our domain received; our company. But
this isn't a really useful form for the data
and, you know, maybe at some point, you know,
SaaSy Voice would implement some really great
reporting features but, you know, that's a
lot of work to do. There's actually a really
easy, you know, tool out there that a lot
of people know how to do reporting in and
it's just spreadsheet. So, you know, rather
than building a lot of, you know, rich reporting
features into the app, we just added a very
quick ability for a user to export the call
log into Google Apps and that's done as a
spreadsheet. So we'll see that spreadsheet
open up in a sec, and I'm just got to reformat
it a little bit just to make it prettier and
let's do a little bit of quick analysis. I
want to find out who has the most phone calls.
So, let's do employee and number of calls
and get all the unique users and let's get
a count of their calls. There you go. So I
get how many calls everyone made, and let's
just make a little chart out of this; to do
insert chart. The bar chart seems pretty reasonable,
save it, and now I got the nice, you know,
a very quick, a very easy visualization of
who's getting the most phone calls in our
domain and you can see here it's Joe, Billy
and Steve, a very easy thing to do. So we'll
see, you know, how we did this last two integrations.
This is actually very similar to what we did
with the Provisioning API. On the context,
very similar again, we create our clients;
we request information about the contacts
for that user, and here's one difference between
what you saw with the provisioning API because
contacts are owned by an individual user.
In order to make the request, you need to
specify which user you're acting on behalf
of. And the way you do that with tool like
an OAuth is by including a query parameter
that is xoauth_requestor_id. The value of
that is simply the email address of that user.
So basically say we get the, you know, get
the email of the currently logged in user,
add that to our query and now we can go fetch
the contacts. Just like we did with the Provisioning
API, we can simply iterate through those results,
parse into a form that's more suitable for
application. We want to do some things like
indexes by phone numbers. And, you know, now
we can use this. So now I can keep that in
memory, I can keep that in memcache, and just
look up my phone number every time I get a
voicemail, show the contact, much more useful
than just basic information from caller ID.
The Docs integration is a little bit different.
The first thing we need to do is we actually
need a file to upload. So, a little helper
method to write out at CSV file, not very
interesting code to take a look at but, you
know, once we do this, we have a file that's
on our, or just a temp file on disk. But,
you know, then we do what we did before. We
create our client, on this case, gives us
a DocsClient that makes it easy. Like, Contacts,
we also need to specify the requestor because
Docs are owned by individual users. We'll
name it with the timestamp so users can know
when this log was generated and then upload
the file as a CSV. By telling it it's a CSV
file, Google Apps will know how to convert
that into a spreadsheet and the only reason
we're using this CSV file here is just because
it's just a really simple way of getting data
into a spreadsheet. There actually is a Spreadsheet
API that lets you work with individual cells.
But for something like a log file, it's just
way too complicated when a CSV file will do
the same job. The last thing we want to do
is once we've uploaded the doc is pull out
the edit URL for that so we can open up the
spreadsheet for the administrator to actually
start using. Again, we just take resulting
entry, iterate through the links to find the
alternate representation; we have this URL.
And now, once the file is uploaded, we can
redirect the user over to the Google Apps
or in a pop-up or in another tab and you know,
they can actually use the data and start analyzing
it. So, before I hand it back to Ryan, just
talk bout gadgets, I just want to do a quick
recap. What you saw is without adding a lot
of code to the application, we were able to
significantly improve the user experience.
We were able to add single a sign on with
OpenIDs, so a user has no longer had to expositely
create accounts or setup a new passwords.
We were able to make the setup process for
the application a lot faster. As an administrator,
I didn't have to enter a lot of information
to start using the applications. And then
from the user's perspective, we were able
to add some features that made the application
and the combination of Google Apps and SaaSy
Voice a better experience and if they were
a stand alone application. We're able to use
the context to enrich the experience and we're
able to export data from our application into
tools like Spreadsheets that the administrators
are already familiar with. So that's all I
have. I'm going to hand it over to Ryan and
he's going to talk to you about gadgets.
>> BOYD: Thanks, Steve. So what Steve talked
about was really taking Google Apps data and
integrating that with your applications elsewhere
on the Web to make them user experience a
lot easier. Gadgets are a way to do a little
bit of the reverse. Many users spent a lot
of their day inside email. It's an unfortunate,
I know, I really don't enjoy it that much
either but, they spent a lot of times inside
email or inside Calendar, inside these other
applications that are part of Google Apps,
and you want a way to take your application
put it inside those applications. This is
what gadgets are all about. Gadgets are really
your real state inside Google Apps. So there
are many different types of gadgets. I list
them here where we're talking about some of
them. Two new types of gadgets were actually
announced this week. We have Gmail contextual
gadgets, we just launched yesterday. I'm going
to show you examples of those, and then Wave
gadgets. Well, Wave has been around for a
while and Wave gadgets have been around for
a while but just this morning, they announced
the ability of Wave for Google Apps, so that's
an exciting additional place that you can
integrate your applications into. All of these
use the open social gadgets specification,
we're not going to get into details of that,
really just showing you the different use-cases
for gadgets and hopefully will inspire you
for your applications. Gmail contextual gadgets,
these are really awesome. These are perhaps
one of my favorite launches that we've done
recently, that just happened yesterday and
really, they like to detect the content of
email by regular expressions and display a
gadget based off of that. The gadget gets
displayed right below the email, I'll show
you one here, and basically it allows you
to put the business information that a user
needs to have, right in front of them in the
context to their email where they can immediately
take action on it without opening up a new
browser or tab to your application. So here
is what a Gmail looks like and here, do you
see that red arrow pointing to a gadget? So
this is an email from Steve to me saying,
"John would like us to incorporate his company,
please let me know the next steps." And you
can see at the bottom here there's a gadget.
This gadget is actually the Manymoon gadget.
Manymoon is a project management application
that's available in the Google Apps marketplace.
And what this gadget allows you to do is immediately
take action on that and create a project or
sign a task. So in this case the gadget actually
automatically pulled in a subject of the message,
John Smith & Company. I added the word incorporated
on the front there, and then it has a place
for assigning members to these projects. So
I want to sign it back to you, Steve, to work
on this project, and also invite an additional
user Kim in my company and those things can
all be auto completed from the context API
that Steve talked about. This is a really
awesome contextual gadget. You've seen some
other demos, I don't know, how many of you
saw the Campfire 1, but Appareo there in the
Campfire 1 demo showed there CRM sales force
application that looked up the sender's email
and immediately looked up the information
about that sender in their sales where CRM
system and made that available right in the
context of gadget, so it's really powerful.
The next type of the gadget that I want to
talk about our Calendar sidebar gadgets. Calendar
sidebar gadgets can detect the currently display
date range, can delete currently selected
event and get lots of information about them
and even set information about them in the
events. So why would you want to do this?
Well, the sidebar gadget exists on the sidebar
very much like another gadget and you see
here soon, the Gmail sidebar gadgets but this
time in Calendar. And this is an example of
the TripIt gadget. TripIt for those you who
don't know is like a travel management application,
really make it easy for you to know where
all you're traveling to and it actually integrate
your upcoming travel schedule right inside
Google calendar. There's also another great
Calendar sidebar gadget that you guys should
check out over in the Developer Sandbox that
I just saw this morning. Again, the folks
at Appareo, they make a lot Web based meetings.
They use go-to meeting and they actually created
a Calendar sidebar gadget that allows them
to create a go-to meeting directly from an
event. So the text with the event is reading
all the information about the date and time
of the event and gives them a one bond and
to click to create a go-to meeting. A really
powerful stuff, I encourage you all to check
that out in the Sandbox. So now, I'm going
to give you a demo to go back to the SaaSy
Voice application that we've been talking
about and we demo the Gmail sidebar gadget.
I kind of alluded to that earlier but I want
to show it to you for real here. So I hop
over my Web browser, run my Gmail log-in screen.
I'm going to log in as Steve here, don't tell
anyone I have Steve's password. And you see
on the left-hand side here is the SaaSy Voice
application and we see that voice mail from
Litigious Larry. In theory, I can click on
this right here, I haven't tested this too
much but, I guess I didn't test it quite enough.
But, you know, basically, I can display the
content of my voicemails right alongside my
email. It's a really great way in order to
take your application and integrate it into
Google Apps where a lot of users are spending
a lot of their time. Okay, now, you may wonder
how these gadgets are distributed. They're
two different types of gadgets for the marketplace
or for marketplace apps. The first one our
admin installed gadgets. So, with the Gmail
contextual gadgets, if your application has
a Gmail contextual gadget, just on the same
page where you grant access to things like
the calendar and the context, the administrator
can also approve installing this contextual
gadget to have access to the email. And this
is installed for every user in the company
and then will trigger on the regular expression
for every user. The other types of gadgets
are users installed. We're certainly looking
at and making more of this available to be
installed, you know, as it, by an administrator.
But, many of this right now are user installed,
and what that means you just provide some
simple instructions to your users, how to
install the gadget in various places like
the Calendar or mail. Now, there's one important
topic here with gadgets and there is another
sessions, actually two sessions tomorrow on
gadgets that I'll get to here shortly but,
just a brief overview on this, the way that
gadgets communicate. Well, gadgets use JavaScript,
using the open social gadget APIs, and they
use JavaScript to request data from the application.
In this case, the application is requesting
data from the SaaSy Voice--I am sorry, the
gadget is requesting data from the SaaSy Voice
application. This data request is all proxy
through the container or Gmail in this case,
and this is all to avoid cross-domain issues.
Gmail then adds information as the container
adds information to this request includes
like the ID of the current viewer and signs
all this information. The SaaSy Voice application
then verifies the signature, verifies its
Google who signed the request and gets out
this open social ID number 34124561 or whatever
it is; gets out that number. Now the next
things we'd like to do, we'd like to have
that application to render the list of voicemails
and display them in the gadget that would
be awesome. But the problem is, is we don't
know who this user is. Who is "34124561"?
This is just their open social ID? Our application
SaaSy Voice is often accessed, you know, as
a full Web application and we don't know with
their open social ID is. So you want to do
open social, you want to do a mapping between
the open social ID and OpenID. And you could
do the OpenID right for, within the gadget,
and I'm going to show you a little demo here
of that. Keep in mind, there's a quick sample,
the user experience can definitely be improved,
I'm sure you have many ways to do that. But
I go down here and this is the very first
time, I, as a user, access this gadget. I
hit sign in, since the marketplace application
it just goes right away, I don't enter grand
access; my administrator has already granted
access for my identity to pass on that application
and the application signs me in. And what
it does after it signs me in is actually stores
in the database table for the SaaSy Voice
application, a mapping between my OpenID and
my open social ID. So from then on for the
life of this user, I never have to do OpenID
in the gadget. OpenID, you know, at times
can be a little slow that first time around
especially within a gadget, if you'd many
different Apps doing at the same time. So
we really want to avoid doing it with every
single time I visit this gadget and this is
the way that you can do that. So now, testing
your application. As you saw, I didn't test
that gadget too well and playing the voicemail.
So, you really want to make sure you test
your application. You guys know this, you're
going to test application thoroughly, but
there are some things that you might want
to keep in mind for testing the Google Apps
integrations of your application. And so there's
a number of things that we've noticed. We
initially work with about, you know, 50 some
odd people to launch on the marketplace when
the marketplace launched in March; 50 some
odd vendors. And now, we have over a 100 vendors
in the marketplace, and so we've gained the
collection of best practices and we put them
together as a checklist on [INDISTINCT]google.com.
So before you submit your app to the marketplace,
please go through this checklist it makes
it a lot easier to get you approved faster
on the marketplace. But there's a lot of great
things here, I'm going to highlight a couple
of them. And, I'm going to back up here that--so
realm mismatch. Realm mismatch, so OpenID,
has this concept of a realm. The realm is
usually your website, usually the root of
your website and what this basically does
is all OpenID request that happened with that
path involved, they're all grouped together,
and you specify a realm in your manifest file.
That manifest XML file that Steve showed you,
you specify the realm there, but you also
specify when you actually perform your OpenID
request. This may all seemed like [INDISTINCT],
you know, got to you but you should recognize
this when you go to launch your app on the
marketplace. Make sure that the value in your
OpenID request, and in your manifest match
up because that allows this white listing
to occur where I never have to, as a user,
authorize passing my identity to the web application
because my administrator hasn't installed
it and already granted that privilege. The
next thing is OpenID for Google Apps. As many
of you are probably aware, there are two different
types of Google accounts. They are Google
consumer accounts, or oftentimes referred
to as Gmail accounts so that they can be on
any domain. And then there are a Google Apps
account which where businesses host their
email on their own custom domain, and Calendar,
and Docs, and that sort of thing. Well, you'd
want to make sure you'd implement OpenID for
Google Apps accounts. We've had some vendors
just to implement the consumer version of
it, but you'd want to make sure you'd implement
for Google Apps accounts. There's only a slight
difference in the discovery in the OpenID
discovery, and the library is actually take
care of that for you, the library that Steve
pointed out. So, but you just really want
to make sure that you actually implement that.
And third, and perhaps most important, support
existing users, when you first launch your
app on the marketplace, I'm assuming you're
going to tell all of your costumers because
your customers actually, you now, are the
ones deprive in asking for this Google Apps
integrations because they use Google Apps
and the user application. You want to make
sure to support those users. We had a couple
apps launched first on the marketplace that
basically treated everyone as new customers.
And, you know, the existing users had the
suboptimal flow through the application. So
you really want to make sure support existing
user this basically means during that installed
flow process, you want to ask, you know, the
person, are you an existing user? If so, enter
your username and password once and we'll
linked that out to the OpenID, if you're not
an existing user, click here and get started
right away. So, this is why you're all here,
selling your application on the marketplace
and we're to go through the different steps
for that. First of all, Steve talked to you
about the manifest file and the format of
that. You want to get that all together in
to your copy buffer, and then you want to
go visit the marketplace. So you go to google.com/appsmarketplace
and then at the top right, you click on sign
in and then you'll be able to create a vendor
profile which is just a little bit of information
about your company, name, and address and
that sort of thing, and then you got to create
a new listing. And here's what the listing
page looks like. The listing page is mostly
marketing information. So if you're developers
in the room, you don't care about most of
that, you can ignore it. Send your marketing
folks an note, ask them for that information
but its things like the name, description
of the application, some key benefits of the
application, and some collateral like screen
chats and videos and that sort of thing. But
the important part here, for as developer
audience are the manifest files. You already
have that manifest there, you copy and paste
it into the manifest box here and then you're
ready. You can then test your application
on as many domains as you want before you
publish it. And when you're ready to publish
it after going through that testing checklist,
of course, you click, I am ready submit this
listing for approval. And then this goes to
a very simple approval process at Google and
we do a couple of things. One, verify that
you've meet that minimum bar of implementing
OpenID. Two, verify that you've respected
the Google brand appropriately and there are
few simple guidelines on that. And three,
you're actually a business app, you're not
trying to launch a bunch of out of material
on the marketplace. So very simple guidelines
for approval and we did that within a couple
days. So now you're actually listed on the
marketplace and you're available for sale.
And here's actually a quote from one of the
vendors that's in the marketplace. You guys
can talk to them again out in the Sandbox
but, they noticed a large numbers of customers
coming in from the Google Apps marketplace.
You can see the graph of that there. But the
key thing I want to point out here is that
their customer site, they're really strong
integration with the various data points as
a key feature of why the purchased the application.
So, you want to make sure not to just have
that minimum bar but to actually do some additional
integration in order to make the lives of
your customers a lot easier. Okay, so that's
basically where we are today. I want to take
about the roadmap and as, you know, as you're
probably all familiar with Google doesn't
often talk about the roadmap. So I want to
talk first about some recent launches with
the Gmail contextual gadgets. We just launch
yesterday as we mentioned. OAuth support for
Gmail's IMAP and SMTP services launched a
couple of months ago and it's a great way
to get access to email whether approved by
the individual user or approved by the domain
administrator. You can use the standard IMAP
and SMTP protocols for that access. And as
you heard today, the launch of Wave for Google
Apps and there are some developer opportunities
available there as well. So the big thing
on the road map are the billing APIs. The
goals of the billing APIs, we didn't go too
much into the administrator view of these
applications during the session. But when
you install an application from the apps marketplace,
all the applications are listed alongside
the other Goggle Apps in the Google Apps control
panel. So the administrator has one view where
they can see all their cloud applications
and configure them and, you know, assign them
appropriately and that sort of thing. Well,
we want to do the same thing for billing.
We want to provide a really simplified invoicing
and payment system for billing so that Google
Apps customers have one place to go to manage
the billing for all their cloud applications
and they don't have to go to, you know, a
bunch of websites around the Web in order
to configure this and enter their credit card
number a dozen times and that's sort of thing.
So we're planning to launch our billing APIs
on the second half of this year. They required
for installable Apps after a transition period
where you can integrate with them and the
revenue sharing starts once the building APIs
are adapted. There's all sorts of different
features in these billing APIs like I mentioned
we now have over a 100 apps in the marketplace
and, you know, a 100 business focused application
that are there and they all have different
billing models and different ways of collecting
payment from their customers. We're well aware
of that and we're going to be working with
them as we design and implement these APIs
to make sure that as many possible use-cases
of billing are met before we release these
billing APIs. So to learn more about all of
this, there are numbers of different I/O sessions
coming up. Tomorrow, I'm going to be doing
a session along with Dave Premer, a fellow
engineer on OpenID and OAuth for Google Apps.
And this session is not going to dive into
the details of the protocols, but he's really
going to help you understand when each of
these flavors of OpenID and OAuth should be
used, for what types of applications and for
what types of users scenarios. Then we're
going to follow those sessions with two sessions
by Dan Holeyvolt on our gadgets team and he's
going to be talking about gadgets for Google
Apps and then dive into the details of Gmail
contextual gadgets that launched yesterday.
So I encourage you all to check those out
and then there are number of different online
resources available. We have a site for our
business and marketing folks to learn about
the value proposition of the Google Apps marketplace,
a site for the technical folks to learn how
to code, their integration. If you all just
want to go shopping, I mean, I'd loved for
you to all launch an app on the marketplace,
but if you just want to go shopping, I'm going
to stop you there's the URL, go by a bunch
of apps, I'm sure your fellow developers will
be happy with that. And if you don't have
Google Apps, I'm not quite sure why you're
in this room currently but, you can go to
google.com/a and by Google Apps or use the
phrase, [INDISTINCT] as well. So now we're
going to go over into our question and answer
period. I'm going to open up moderator, but
before I do that I want to encourage all of
you to stop by the Sandbox and see all the
different types of applications. Many of the
Sandbox partners are actually in the marketplace
and they do also have t-shirts to hand out
to you. You may to listen to, about their
application but I'm sure you'll enjoy it.
To get a t-shirt, an awesome t-shirt for the
Google Apps marketplace, so stop by there
and we'll also be around obviously overtime.
So you can step up to the mics and we can
go over to the moderator. Well, I'm going
over to the moderator want to take the first
question from the mic here. [INDISTINCT] your
moderator. Jared with AwayFind, we were one
of your contextual gadgets; thank you, guys
for your help. I'm just curious if in the
future, in the process of an admin installing
for the entire domain, if they'll have any
ability to be kind of a little bit more granular
in terms of who they select to have a particular
application of it as to be the kind of the
whole thing at once.
>> BAZYL: Yeah, I mean, that's definitely
a request that we hear often and it's something
that we're looking at doing. It's, basically,
right now, when the domain administrator installs
an app on the Google Apps marketplace, it's
immediately available to all users in the
domain. There are sometimes types of applications
where it's more relevant for the application
to only be available to a subset of users
whether it'd be a particular group of people
like the payroll department or things like
that. And so, yeah, it's definitely something
that we're looking into. I don't have any
promises on dates or a promise that we'll
do it but, it is something well aware of as
a constant mean.
>> Thanks.
>> BAZYL: So, let's go through here on this
presenter view. Is there a way to implement
setup authentication or--sorry, step up authentication
even after a single sign on through OpenID.
Steve?
>> BOYD: Who asked that question? Or...
>> BAZYL: Someone raised their hand.
>> BOYD: I'm not quite sure what the feature
is asking for. There is an extension to OpenID
for people that need to force authentication
if you want to make sure that, you know, user
is, you know, really at their keyboard to
call the provider authentication policy extension.
And you can basically say, you know, make
sure the user has been logged in within the
last N seconds. So you can do, you know, 15
minutes or whatever and it's a way that you
can make sure that the user is present. In
terms of things like strong authentication,
that's not a feature that we have in Google
Apps at this time. But, you know, if whoever
asked that question, if you can clarify what
you're looking for it would help.
>> BAZYL: You know, come and see us after
the session as well. All right, another question
at the mic.
>> Okay, in the presentation to get the data
access from the user, we need to use 2-legged
OAuth, but I am wondering if we can use 3-legged
OAuth as well.
>> BAZYL: Yes, you can you can--go ahead.
>> Is it supported as well?
>> BAZYL: So 2-legged OAuth, we belief has
some advantages for the administrators and
for the end-users. 2-legged OAuth basically
has the advantage that the administrator is
granting access to the data and it's granted
once by the administrator instead of by each
of the individual users, which is 3-legged
OAuth is used for. We think this has a distinctive
advantage because the administrator is the
one that often owns the data and has the rights
to grant access to it. Individual users maybe
kind of confused as to whether it is okay
with their company security policies, but
the administrators are the ones that can do
that. So that being said, we do actually have
a number of apps in the marketplace that do
use 3-legged OAuth to access users' data and
that they prompt individual users for access
to their data, and that's fine. There's a
few little bits in the UI of the marketplace
that are automated based off like the 2-legged
OAuth, and being in the manifest so won't
get those. But you can, you know, use 3-legged
OAuth if you want in a marketplace application.
Just, you know, keep your users in mind and
figure out what the best ways for them.
>> Yeah.
>> BOYD: The only we'd discourage with 3-legged
is using the OpenID OAuth Hybrid mode that
allows you to combine them because that will
break the white listing. And there's OpenID
on premier domains is disabled by default,
so you can actually need a very bad user experience
on premier domains if you use hybrid. But,
you can still do OpenID and OAuth separately
and that will work fine.
>> BAZYL: Thanks. So next we'll take quickly
is from the moderator. Is there a way to integrate
Google Talk like they did in JIRA Studio?
So, Google Talk actually uses the open standard
XMPP for communication and the only issue
with Google Talk right now is that it does
require the user's username and password to
login to it. As I mentioned earlier, we've
launched OAuth support for our IMAP and SMTPs.
So we're not opposed to extending standard
protocols and adding OAuth support to make
it more secure. But, you know, we don't have
announced yet that the availability for that
for XMPP or Google Talk, it's certainly something
that we're considering. So, next up. Do we
have any other question at the mic? No? Okay,
so in the demonstration all the domains users
were provisioned and charged once. Can the
administrator choose--so this was the same
question from the folks at AwayFind. In terms
of, to clarify this is when you install a
marketplace application as a domain administrator,
the application is installed and available
in the universal navigation, the bar at the
top of email Calendar, et cetera. It's installed
and available for all the different users
but you can actually as a vendor in the marketplace
choose to bill however you want. So, you can
choose to say that, you know, only five users
access this application this month even though
there are 50 people in the company so I'm
only going to bill for five users. Or you
can actually do name the licenses where during
the administrator flows, you actually ask
the administrator to list the people in their
company that they want to have access to the
application and you can manage that yourself.
We're just not doing it in automated fashion
yet on our side, but that, you know, again,
this is something that we're definitely considering.
>> One quick question. What you're advising
regarding Google Apps Engine application because
in Google Apps Engine you have users API,
but in the Google Apps marketplace you are
pushing an OpenID flows so you have only one
instance of your application. So, I don't
know what's the best practice there?
>> BAZYL: Sure, so we do have a number of
different App Engine apps that are in the
marketplace. Most of them don't use the user
API, they just use OpenID or have their method
of authenticating against the Datastore and
things like that. You can certainly take that
strategy. We are certainly looking at how
to make the development process easier for
App Engine apps to hook in to things like
OpenID. There's nothing out there yet that
does that exactly. But, so, my recommendation
at this point would be not to use the user's
API instead use OpenID. I don't know if that's
practical if you already have launched that,
but I'm happy to talk with you about it after
this session and we can go to details.
>> Thanks.
>> BAZYL: Sure.
>> So, on your demo you were able to setup
accounts for existing users. Can you hook
up to the user creation event for, you know,
if you add new users to your domain?
>> BAZYL: So, the Provisioning API when you
get access by 2-legged OAuth, if the domain
administrator grants you access by a 2-legged
OAuth during the install process, you can
actually then access that API offline. That's
one of the benefits of the 2-legged OAuth
is that the user doesn't necessarily have
to be at the keyboard for you to access the
API. So you could actually query the Provisioning
API and see if there are new users and set
those users up. Or do a something like send
an email to the domain administrator and say,
"Hey, we see the following new users. Click
on this link below to setup them up or use
the contextual gadgets and do that all within
the concept." In the context of the email,
all sorts of different ways that you can handle
that, but you could handle the users in a
later flow. Like I was trying to allude to
it's not, as far as Google is concerned at
this point, the apps installed for the entire
domain, as an application developer, you can
choose how to restrict access and how to manage
that access at this point.
>> BOYD: One other note on that. A lot of
the apps in the marketplace even though they
may have a setup process in large of what
we showed, they don't actually create the
user accounts until the first time the user
logs in that's one of the advantages with
the OpenID and the attribute exchange is the
same information that we got with the Provisioning
API. We just as easily could have got the
very first time that user hit the app and
then just, you know, add them on demand.
>> BAZYL: So, the question here. Does that
supply to Mobile Apps if one has an enterprise
mobile version? So right now, like the universal
navigation flow and all isn't available on
the mobile versions of our applications. Although
certainly if one of these users that has bought
the application through the Google Apps marketplace
could access your mobile version and do OpenID
flow, you know, in a mobile browser just the
same. And then the final question; is the
$100 onetime per application or per developer?
It is per developer. So each vendor account
has a $100 one time fee and then you can list
as many unique applications in the marketplace
as you want after paying that one time fee.
And then will there be recurring billing?
Recurring billing is obviously a feature that
a lot of apps in the marketplace use. That's
definitely something that we're considering
for as we're designing the billing API. And
that's all. Feel free to catch-up with us
after this session or we'll be in office hours
in the Sandbox and that sort of thing and
ask any additional questions you have. And
don't forget to pickup your t-shirt after
talking with the Sandbox partners. All right.